I'm from the 80s and 90s we made fun of
each other for much more aggressive [__]
than that fair enough the question about
buying Candor when someone has food
stuck in their teeth do you tell them or
you hope that it'll just go away on its
own I'ma go away in its own
but I actually think there's something
else going on with this question this
falls in the category of like massive
things that don't [__] matter like
the concept of something stuck in one's
tooth being something socially awkward I
think is a humongous problem by the way
until I got into my 40s I didn't even
realize it was like something people
gave a [__] about really yeah not in
high school no